great pronunciation on gun he'll never
learn pronunciation will he
no he's team god not the correct team
god he had me until he pronounced
gun gun he's pronouncing that
please oh my god gun gun
mark i love you by the way but when i
hear mark do it it's more of a gun
gong he says gone to me okay so
apparently i'm saying the name wrong but
there's only one way to figure out
that's true so one second
let's
[Music]
you're japanese right which means you
speak japanese right
i think so okay you know hunter hunter
you've seen this show
yeah what's the main character's name
all right so whatever i made a mistake
his name is gun
and this week i'm covering some crazy
material
last week i gave you my review of the
first arc of this story and in it i
uncovered some
subtle indications of an emotional
maturity and attention to detail
that gained my praise early on but did
the story in these more recent arcs
let me down or did they continue the
trend in an upwards direction
find out today as i explore the two
short but powerful arcs that build upon
the first in crazy and
surprising ways welcome back everyone to
my blind review of one of the shonen
genres modern greats
this is hunter hunter's zoldick family
and heavens arena
[Music]
she
the note that we left the last arc with
was one of horror
mystery and pursuit having spent a
considerable amount of time
struggling to attain their respective
hunter licenses after having done so
because of what happened with kilua it
didn't feel like a moment of celebration
but instead one of great loss and
shock gong sought after the hunter
license but in his journey to acquire it
he made a lifelong friend group wherein
each member cared tremendously for each
other and casting my mind back to the
very first chapter when i saw gong
sat on his own fishing the fact he has
all of these people to fall back on must
mean a great deal to him now and when he
grabbed illumi's arm to reprimand him
there must have been much like the small
animal in chapter one
a great deal of self-projection unto
killaba from god
he doesn't want to be left behind and so
no matter what he can't let killua
believe he doesn't have a companion in
him
someone that truly cares no matter the
circumstances
and these are pretty dire circumstances
if you think about it take a character
like luffy
goku or even any of the jojo's really
and plot them into this setting with
this information
while i'm sure they would be able to see
the nuance of the situation and
eventually understand that kilauea was
traumatized by his family they would in
some shape or form care that he
killed someone but gong never even
mentions it while the person killable
ultimately killed wasn't a noteworthy
character by any stretch of the
imagination one of the few lines he did
have
painted him as a man with a noble
disposition stating that he
specifically wouldn't hurt or fight a
child out of principle and
in the end it was a child that killed
him stabbed in the back
but no matter what gong is determined to
be there 4 kilowatt
which is exactly where we find ourselves
heading on this adventure i mentioned
last week that gang and kilauea
are almost two sides of the same coin
each experiencing similar problems but
on different sides of the spectrum
through gong's conversation and actions
across the first arc it's been made
explicitly clear that he doesn't see
value in himself due to a deep sense of
inadequacy brought on potentially by
abandonment issues and kilowatt feels an
overbearing sense of assuredness due to
his family's relentless desire to be
in his life both gang killer will feel
like they are on a shared journey
exploring different aspects of the
family theme on different sides of the
spectrum
in other words they're sort of opposites
demonstrating perhaps what sort of toll
toxic or neglectful family dynamics can
have on a child
and if you believe it this is sort of
communicated visually too
just by looking at these characters you
can tell that they are similar but also
kind of the opposite however you would
only be able to recognize this fully in
the manga
in it gong and kilauea are both the same
age gender and height but
while gong has tall black spiky hair
kiru's hair is styled
down and is white furthermore during
this section of the story in the battle
arena which specifically focuses on
their relationship and adventure
together kilauea is further in contrast
with gong
by wearing a black top while gong isn't
filled in and therefore appears white so
in addition to tagashi's choices serving
to differentiate the characters for easy
reading they subtly communicate this
aspect
also through the visuals and little did
i know as gang kuropika and leorion now
make their way to killua's family home
a world of hurt was once again waiting
for the young boy with the spiky hair
zoldick family arc this arc is
remarkably short and with it only being
five chapters long i wasn't exactly
expecting much from it and in a way i
was kind of correct but that's not to
say interesting stuff doesn't happen
within this yet
unknown material within its chapter 39
opening what first caught my eye was an
elegant dialogue exchange between our
heroic trio
reminding me exactly why i love
tagashi's writing as they approach
kilauea's intimidating mountain home
looming over the horizon this panel
captures each respective character
perfectly as they react to the sight of
said mountain kuripika looking ahead
wants to make a plan leorio looking for
security wants to locate a place to stay
first and gon
just wants to see his friend you could
remove the character artwork in this
panel and still know
quite easily who's talking stuff like
this isn't flashy or praised very often
but
in my opinion these are fundamentals
that do most of the heavy lifting when
it comes to
character writing everything they say is
informed by who they are
and not by what makes the plot more
interesting which by default
makes each of these characters that much
more interesting i mean as they approach
the foot of the mountain after coming to
a halt when faced by the walls
surrounding it we're told the rules on
how to get through and the consequences
of jumping over
normally this would result in a
rebellious streak or excitement building
in the main character
who might want to test his new abilities
against these obstacles up ahead
lord knows that formula works for other
series but
not gone that's not who he is in fact he
has no interest in being tested
whatsoever he's there
to see his friend and if that makes him
an intruder then so be it
it's incredibly strong character writing
that once again tears down the facade of
this shonen world
with reality and genuine reason which
are honestly what i've come to recognize
as hunter hunter's greatest strengths
and again similarly to the sea captain
that pointed him in the right direction
early in the first arc
this jaded perimeter guard in a similar
fashion is impressed by gong and
decides to allow him to try and make
contact with
the family using his phone notice how
everything is being informed by the
character it's like in order to
highlight the qualities of gun's
personality
togashi places him in standard shonen
situations and lets the contrast do all
the talking
you guys were expecting a fight here
well how about a reasonable argument
and a phone call
and oddly enough this sort of resolution
makes me that much more invested because
i now understand that i am watching a
character and not
a plot device however after hearing a
not so nice response from one of the
butlers
gone is forced to reconsider his next
course of action if he barges his way in
he risks the lives of his friends and
places the security guard in a position
where he might meet harm also
and when faced by those facts he decides
the only course of action is to play
ball and compete
in these challenges the first being able
to push open the giant stone doors
if they can do that then they earn the
right to advance onward without putting
anyone in unnecessary danger
obviously they get through it in the end
but what i found interesting during this
section wasn't necessarily the
overcoming of the challenges but instead
the rapid healing process that god
undergoes remember this is a kid that
had his arm broken by hanzo
at the end of the last arc how did he
heal it so fast there's definitely
something to this
as this won't be the only time this
healing ability is admonished by god
in this video and it's just as well for
him that he healed up all nice and
everything because
now they are proceeding to the
[Music]
next challenge this scene is honestly
pretty hard to watch
the only thing gon wants to do is to
meet his friend kilaba who he fears is
being manipulated and hurt right now he
refuses
to yield to anything that says that he
can't do what he believes to be a simple
request
and in pursuit of this end he ends up
being beaten
alive by this apprentice girl by the
name of canary
i will say however that after being
shown the 1999 and 2011 anime
adaptations of this scene the 2011
version
sort of let the site down in this
instance in my opinion
the purpose behind this scene is to
demonstrate the unyielding force of gone
versus the trained immovable
object in canary and to minimize the
degree of suffering god absorbs to see
his friend diminishes the impact this
scene is designed in both the 1999 anime
and the original manga to
have furthermore on the censorship front
the scene
is meant to show a level of abuse and
conflict in canary's mind as she
struggles to continue under the weight
of her own conscience
this scene looks great in the manga and
great once again in the 1999 version but
in 2011's anime
because they don't really want to show
blood or that much gore
it looks comparatively lesser i think
particularly compared to how impactful
this sudden attack on canary hits
in the other versions of the story
something that i obviously like about
gun
is how emotionally aware he is of other
people and the consequences his actions
might bring
unto those individuals for the same
reason he didn't press the issue with
the security guard he doesn't cause
further harm
to come to the apprentice and yet he
doesn't seem to have any regard for his
own well-being or
safety in this scene also which
perfectly reflects his negative sense of
self-worth illuminated in the prior arc
during the conversation with coderpica
but
all of that aside this mini arc sort of
felt strange and off-balance and i mean
that in the best way possible i was very
much excited to see a standoff of some
description on this compound for kilauea
but
instead his dad just lets him go in an
encouraging way
now obviously he has ulterior motives at
play here but yeah
kilauea gets to go free now there's one
more scene that follows this before they
ultimately leave and
it's this coin trick performed by the
butlers gun is surprisingly great at it
and
looking back at the scene now i think
this was clearly a test
to see just how proficient these kids
were in a particular
technique something called nen gets
brought up later but
now i'll just say i think that played a
role here and overall it was a cute and
fun scene that killed some time before
killer was showed up and that's pretty
much the first of these two arcs
overall i liked it and found that
entertaining i thought the character
writing was on point and brilliant and
the pacing again was snappy hunter
hunter in this case continues to be a
surprisingly easy manga to digest
and i hope it continues in that
direction as we dive into
heaven's arena arc
of the two arcs i'll be exploring today
the heavens arena portion is clearly
explored in greater detail it's an arc
with a beginning
and an end and interestingly the first
move of this arc is to remove
half of the cast kurupika and lyorio as
mentioned in the earlier arcs have
goals and aspirations of their own and
so this entire arc is centrally focused
around
gun and killua but this isn't goodbye
forever instead it's a see you later of
sorts
later being specifically september 1st
in york new city
gol wants to eventually rematch hisoka
to give him back the id he took
and so in the meantime gun and kilowatt
are faced with a dilemma how to train
and get money for food and shelter
and as it happens to be the case kilauea
is familiar with
something called heaven's arena
[Music]
once again this section is predicated on
a simple challenge type concept
the goal is to get to the top of the
heavens arena with each passing floor
the higher one goes the more difficult
the competition gets and in addition to
that the higher they get the more money
they ultimately stand to win
in theory they have six months to train
and prepare for york new city and this
is where they'll do it and once again
the choice that they make to spend their
time here and participate in the tower
challenge over the coming months stems
from kilauea and gone respectively
through small dialogue exchanges we
learned that kilauea was left here as a
six-year-old child
and tasked with reaching the 200th floor
before he could return home with that
small piece of information we get a
brief glimpse into kilowatt's past
as well as a short-term goal for us as
an audience to shoot for as
everything from the 200th floor and
above will be entirely new to kilauea
and by extension us
the audience so in a nutshell this arc
is pretty much chronicling gone on
kilowatt's time
and journey in climbing the levels of
this building through intense physical
competition
and it is great now naturally the
introductory bouts help both the
officials of the battle arena and us as
an audience to get a feel for how
powerful our two protagonists are when
pitted against
the other contestants of the heavens
arena and in these opening matches
tagashi makes use of a rudimentary but
ultimately effective visual trick
pinning a small character against a
confident bigger bully type character
it's very reminiscent of old school
dragon ball with goku in the various
tournaments he participated in
as a child and the satisfaction of these
scenes comes specifically from these
cocky brutes getting a taste of their
own medicine courtesy of a smaller
modest child
it's also funny watching gone kilauea
get immediately advised to go to the
50th level already after only one bout
now killable was technically advised to
go higher but i like how he decided to
stick around with his friend
throughout it's around this time also in
the story we meet a competent but young
martial artist called zushi
i love sushi i love japan period and
after he demonstrates a technique that
scared kilowatt half to death our two
protagonists end up meeting with his
master
called wing now before i move on i feel
like i need to apologize in advance
as someone that grew up as a teen in the
late 2000s and early 2010s
south park was about as popular as it
ever had been and in a particular
episode there was this old chinese woman
that gets beaten unconscious in a boxing
match
while singing a lovely song now this
poor woman
is also called wing and so whenever i
heard
this guy's name uttered in the story i
couldn't help but
automatically think of wing from south
park getting brutalized in the face
there's no greater point i'm trying to
make here other than to help you all
realize and understand
what was going through my mind whenever
this person's name was uttered so let's
move on thanks to zushi and
wing i became aware of a particular
mechanic in this world called nen
it's this universe's magic system and i
love it not just because of its inherent
awesomeness which i want to talk about
in a second but also because it provides
greater explanations as to what happened
in the forest with hisoka and gone the
fight between illumi and kilauea in the
previous arc
and even earlier in this video when
killua's mother made herself known and
launched an attack it helps to explain
all of this quite well and somewhat
interestingly
this gave me pause for thought obviously
kilowatt has been here before and the
entire arc is predicated on that fact
but when he was here last he was working
under orders from his father to reach
the 200th floor and then come home
now that we've been familiarized with
this arc we understand that nen
is a key component to all of the fights
pretty much from the 200th floor and
above and we know that illumi utilized
that power too
so i ask why has kilwen not only never
used
nen but also never seen it or heard of
it prior to this very meeting with wing
it seems like something his father or
family would have taught or exposed to
him at some point given their knowledge
of it and this lack of knowledge leads
the two boys to
once they qualify for the 200 floor to
run into some trouble
[Music]
yeah so uh this lovely and not at all
suspiciously flirtatious or creepy
toward children killer clown man little
kid lover
is sitting there putting up a force
field of sorts in front of the two kids
and this is somewhat disconcerting
because they need to register before
midnight for the 200th floor
otherwise they lose their placing and so
they seek out wing once again to help
them master one of the four fundamentals
of nen to make their way past him to
register
after which gong finally gets a taste of
what the 200th floor is competition
looks like
they all use nen and even though gun
demonstrates great promise in his
opening bout managing to even
[Music]
i mean yeah he uses ultra instinct and
dodges the dude's beyblades for hours
eventually he does fall though so time
to get back to the drawing board and on
this drawing board i think it's time for
me to finally talk about nen because
it's honestly one of the more
complicated and brilliant power systems
i've come across
power systems in anime offer a lot of
upsides the skill of the battles gets
larger making them more cinematic and it
helps to individualize a particular
series in a sea of other popular more
derivative works
what's one piece without devil fruits
what's dragon ball without key
manipulation could you imagine the
dragon ball series without the
kamehameha
or the super saiyan transformations
probably not because
that system is a fundamental part of our
enjoyment with the series largely
however with those upsides potentially
come negatives and drawbacks dragon
ball's power system famously runs into
issues with power creep as our main
characters go from training on a beach
with an old man to
literally training with the gods
themselves and that's all down to the
structure of the system we're talking
about right now it most definitely has
its benefits but it's important to also
acknowledge its shortcomings
nen however seems to have an appreciably
different approach
than many other power systems i've seen
in fact i don't think i've come across
any that match it perfectly whether
that's a good or a bad thing is still up
in the air but
time will most definitely tell from an
aesthetics or visual standpoint it's
sort of like jojo's stanz
meets dragon ball's key if you don't use
nen you can't see n much like stanz and
jojo and the auras particularly in the
manga look distinctly dragon ball
however mechanically they are
very different and this to be honest i'm
really excited to see explored further
this nenpower system is sort of like a
more complicated iteration on what i
recognize as
avatar the last airbenders bending
system for the avatar state
and maybe even one piece's devil fruit
system to some degree though obviously
hunter hunter came before avatar
similarly to avatar each person seems to
fall under a neat category but
unlike avatar anyone can learn the other
types available to them as
sort of nen seems to also work on a
chart system wherein the closer one's
natural nen type
is to another type the easier it will be
to master and implement alongside his
current original one particularly
compared to the ones farther away on the
chart
in avatar aang seemed to have similar
issues being an airbender he was able to
master water and fire much easier than
his natural opposite in earth bending
which required significantly more work
nen from my understanding for the most
part shares in that same principle
the chart looks like this and includes
nen types like enhancer
transmuter conjurer etc they each offer
different approaches to nin and that's
honestly great getting plenty of variety
speaking as someone that's only just met
this power system mechanically i think
it's super interesting and i can't fault
it right now
in many respects i think it's better
than avatar's system because it frees up
this mechanic to work as the checks and
balance system by which
every net user must operate not just one
individual but with that said
unlike avatar pokemon one piece or even
dragon ball which all have easily
understood and intuitive power systems
nen has a larger learning curve while it
makes sense and can be understood
i don't think the personality traits
associated with each various type
can be understood as easily as water is
the opposite of fire in avatar or
pokemon
in hunter hunter these traits are things
one must learn through exposure to the
property and
in reading the latter material of this
arc i found myself having to refer back
to the nand chart numerous times in
order to make sense of or to figure out
where
one end user was in relation to another
because to me
it's not obvious that the opposite of
transmuter is manipulator now i'm not
suggesting that this is an absolute
negative as it may very well lead me to
being more easily surprised later on
down the line as characters experiment
with men further and further outside of
their comfort zones but i will say that
there's a reason why dragon ball's key
avatars bending and one piece's devil
fruits are so ubiquitous and part of pop
culture today and why i have never heard
of nen prior to the making of these
videos
and honestly i think that's a shame
because i sincerely think this system
has so much more to offer than i can
fully appreciate at this moment in time
which is made super obvious given the
fights that unfold after gone and
kilauea proceed with their training
under
wing's wing now that's not to say that
the story doesn't go to considerable
lengths to help communicate the basic
concept of men to us
apart from wings schooling us in the
four basic tenets of ten
hatsu ren and zetsu were also shown how
most of each of these play
into various fights zushi's initial
fight with kilaba on the 50th floor
demonstrated rent guido's first fight
with gun demonstrates an application of
nen in various forms and gun second
fight with him
after gohan's training demonstrated the
hole in guido's strategy while also
informing us that an emotional
attachment to an object strengthens the
name of that object it became very
interesting
because i just know there's a sad story
behind that fishing rod now and
okay hold it together mark primarily
this second fight served to highlight a
whole in guido strategy with this very
flaw
being brilliantly highlighted perhaps
more clearly in this subsequent fight
castro was demonstrated early on to be a
powerful nen user but in the end failed
to defeat
hisoka because he required a lot of
energy to pull off this ambitious and
effective but ultimately ill-matched
technique to his nen type because
castro's n-type wasn't naturally
effective in learning this skill
the level of focus and energy required
to pull it off became castro's downfall
all the while hisoka manages to make
himself look
even more intimidating and terrifying
unfazed by his arm's dismemberment
i loved this fight in the manga and
unfortunately i learned that
in the 1999 anime adaptation it pretty
much
cuts it all out with only a few short
highlights of it left included now this
may or may not have played a role in
this but i did notice during my reading
that a viewers survey was conducted
during this section and kilauea was seen
as the clear fan favorite with gun
being in third place i find this
interesting because instead of keeping
the entire hisoka and castro fight like
the manga and the 2011 anime did the
1999 anime adaptation decided to add a
filler fight with killua instead
now i have no idea if this was
censorship or
a want to include kilauea or something
else entirely i just wish they didn't
cut it with that said though i do want
to draw attention to a piece of filler
in the 1999 anime that i
absolutely adored while going up and
down the various levels of the heavens
arena both gone and kilauea encountered
this woman operating the elevator
[Music]
she's a very minor character in the
manga but in the anime she's the vehicle
for some terrific comedic moments with
her last encounter with the boys being
particularly hilarious
with that aside i think possibly the
coolest reveal from this act for me
was one of these two things hisoka's
spider tattoo being revealed after his
fight with castro being the first
the fact that this man now is tied not
only to gom but
also kurupika definitely piqued my
interest but the most fun revelation of
this arc has to be that the nen training
was
all part of their hunter training in
other words the hunter exams were still
sort of
ongoing it's really cool to hear how
others are getting on and it makes a lot
of sense in universe considering the
sort of people we've come to familiarize
ourselves with in this section but even
with that said
if i was living in this world i don't
think i could trust anyone after someone
told me this
but all of that aside we finally find
ourselves at the climax of this arc
hisoka versus gon for the record these
characters respective journeys in this
series thus far have been somewhat
intertwined
gon seems to be both scared and
motivated by hisoka's looming presence
and hisoka
is interested in gone and with visuals
like these i'm not sure what that means
nor do i think i want to know but
anyways this fight spans three entire
chapters and for the most part is
all action the drawings in these
chapters are fantastic and the action
flows incredibly well
ease of deciphering and reading through
a particular page is what i look for the
most and these chapters concerning this
fight absolutely deliver on that premise
additionally for my benefit i was shown
both the 1999 and the 2011 version of
this fight too
funnily enough one thing that was
pointed out to me was how weird the
sound effects towards the start of the
1999's version of the fight were
i mean check it out
additionally on this front one of the
driving narrative talking points after
this fight concludes is that of the
referee is judging in the manga it feels
like
maybe gone gets something of a raw deal
but it's well within the realms of
plausibility but
this is very different in the anime
because the anime needs to fill in the
action segments to give the fight the
appropriate pacing and because of this
the flurry of strikes and attacks gun
ends up landing on hisoka seem
unmistakably dominant
i mean there's one part of this fight
where gon lands dozens of hits and he
barely gets any points for them and so
in the manga
it's possible the ref is acting in good
faith but in the anime it sort of feels
as though the ref has something out for
this little kid
with that said however the 1999 version
of the fight has some incredible
animation with its storyboarding in
certain sections impressing me the most
whether it be the insane angles
attempted or the water droplets flying
through the air these choices to convey
this fight only serve to elevate it
within its medium with the commentator
in the 1999 version clearly loving what
she does
shone through some terrific character
acting animation overall
i loved this fight sequence it's my
favorite fight of the series so far and
i'm very excited to see how things
proceed from here with her two heroes
kilowatt and gone now having completed
their training
gone the enhancer and killer with the
transmuter i am very excited to see how
their powers develop and how their roles
within the story change and grow overall
i thoroughly love these two short acts
of the story i found the zoldic family
arc to be the most emotionally rich
while i found heaven's arena
to offer the most fun and entertainment
not to mention lore concerning men
all of these story arcs seem to
consistently admonish a strong sense of
progression
and fun and now that we have york new
city on the horizon all the while both
gold and kilauea are heading back to
where the series began
i'm very excited to see what more comes
from this
amazing story next week will be my first
video covering york new city and i can
only hope that i am ready for what's to
come within that material
thank you all so much for watching and i
hope to see you all in your new city
next week
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign